this is a CBS News special report I'm 22
Coppola in New York the Labor Department
has just released a new report on
jobless claims showing the economic
damage from the corona virus CBS News
business analyst Jill Schlesinger joins
us to go over the numbers we've had six
point sixteen point eight million people
file in the prior three weeks a huge
horrific number what are the new numbers
deal new number is more than five
million new claims for unemployment
benefits and you know this is just
heart-wrenching
I know it's lower than the previous two
months but to imagine in a four week
span that we have more than 22 million
Americans who are filing for
unemployment claims it is astounding it
is shocking and it is profoundly sad
that is definitely true we've seen this
come in waves push through different
sectors of the economy the fact that
it's five million this week a horrific
number but six million last week does
that suggest we've reached a peak and
we're plateauing well I don't want to be
out there and saying that but it does
look like two autonomous when they
project forward that we will start to
see these claims tail off through the
month of April and that would be really
great news I think the critical question
is how many of these more than 20
million Americans will be actually
coming back into the labor force that to
me is the critical question and really
speaks to how we come out of this
massive recession and some are calling
it the great lockdown recession Joe
we've been following these numbers as
sort of the economic equivalent of the
hospitalization numbers and the death
rate numbers that we see on the health
side of things one of the disconnects on
the economic side is while jobless
claims pile up the stock market is
actually rebounded somewhat what's going
on there well I've always thought that
looking at the stock market it's a sign
of the economy but it's not v-sign the
stock market and the economy are two
very different things remember what our
investors doing when they're buying
shares in a company they are saying in
the future will that company make money
and they are betting maybe months and a
year or two into the future now that
said there are many times in bear
markets that I've witnessed in my
lifetime where we've seen markets rally
from the bottoms and we're up about say
25 26 percent from the low that we reach
back in March of March 23rd there are
times where we rallied up only to see
revisitation of the low levels so if I
were an investor I wouldn't get too
excited about the rally but I wouldn't
be so forlorn because for most of us we
are long-term investors and we are
investing for decades in the future all
right Jill thank you very much 5.2
million additional Americans filing
jobless claims that brings the total
over the past four weeks to more than 20
million roughly the population of
Florida